let me ask you this cuz your Chemistry
with Gunner is pretty crazy we don't get
a lot of uh you know when I was growing
up we had producers and artists lock the
[__] in like the Rizza and wuang Clan
yeah they need to bring that back gangar
with DJ Premier and Guru and but I feel
like you guys are kind of your own
version of that and it's been it's been
like that for a while um how did you
initially meet Gunner we from the same
neighborhood okay so you've known him
for a very long time yeah yeah was he
cuz I always say like between him and
baby over the last like six or seven
years just the like Improvement at just
bars and like actual rapping is like
yeah I don't I'll venture to say we have
never really seen somebody like jumps so
far ahead at just the skill of rapping
in a short amount of time did you always
kind of see that in
him um I think in the beginning it was
just it like any producer um you just
want somebody to rap on your [__] so we
was from the same side we knew each
other we had mutual friends and it was
it was just easy and I knew it was
something different but I can't just say
you know cuz he's very different for
people like like we're used to the sound
now cuz everyone's taken it done their
own version of what gun andb do right
but like 7 years ago 6 years ago 5 years
ago it wasn't the sound everybody was
like what the [__] is this yeah so like
you really had to kind of be like man
this shit's different we just going to
roll with it like you I make beats let
figure this out it felt good you know
what I mean it wasn't it wasn't no
pressure and like you know at at that
time like nobody was doing guitars and I
love the acoustic music and he sounded
good on guitars and it just it just
worked bro it was like it was it was a
natural thing it wasn't anything that
was for so even just seeing something
different the only thing I could see
different was we're going to stay in the
studio the longest our work ethics going
to it matches you know what I mean he's
not leaving before me I'm not leaving
before him and it's it's downn near a
competition so early on that's what we
was doing we leaving the studio 700 in
the morning and coming right back at 12
to the point where like especially those
days right before it popped off I really
remember asking myself what am I doing
this for right you know what I mean I
didn't have much success but I'm like
bro we really going to the studio and we
in the studio all day I don't got no
you're putting all this time and
bandwidth into this and you don't even
know if it's going to work out I don't
even know what we're doing this for you
know what I mean it's like why what do
we what are we try I know we're working
on a project and it was drip season 3 at
the time but you know I didn't know why
we was working so hard and um you know I
I mixed drip season 3 and the same night
he was trying to record and I remember
him telling me like cuz I was pissed I'm
like bro I've been mixing this [__]
Alum all day bro like what do you mean
play some beats I don't got no Beats
I'm tired I want to chill you know what
I mean like bro trust the process BR you
know you know don't burn out and just
play some be just got to keep going we F
to do it and I'm
like crazy
bro but it but it really was the truth
you know what I'm saying and even
comparing to like some of the producers
I came in with my trajectory is been way
further you know what I mean like it's a
lot of guys I came in with but they have
success you know gold success like you
know I'm not happy unless it's Platinum
right and that became a normal thing but
it it was all about what we was putting
into the music and how much time we were
spending on it so that was like that was
like a good lesson that I was able to
learn with him you know what I mean what
is his writing process like is it is it
cuz you know everybody's got their own I
mean I've been in studio with guys where
they just the beat will play for like 5
minutes 10 minutes and they'll just lay
down a bunch of [__] they I like this
part I like this part and then they put
it together yeah kind of I mean he got
his own um recording process but it's
it's not like a you know pin and Pad
type of thing it's like a player beat if
it feel good pull it up you going to do
it and we going to do something else you
know what I mean it's not really a this
or that and it's different every time uh
have you had any cuz I I saw an
interview you did not too long
ago um because I thought it was dope how
everything happened the way it happened
and you stay stood by your guy now you
guys have a number one album A lot of
people say an album of the year last
year snubbed for the Grammy by the way
snub yeah for sure insane yeah snubbed
it happens it's wild it's wild it
happens um but for you have like to kind
of like be that loyal and still be like
yo we locked in cuz you were talking to
him every day when he was locked up I
saw um has like were other relationships
for you in the music industry affected
by that um I don't know yet right you
know what I mean it's it's not weird
when I'm out and when I'm doing stuff
but I mean I don't know yet I I always
been like a a person that just stay in
the studio and keep to myself so I was
never chummy chummy with people to the
point to where I would notice like oh
this guy is acting different or this guy
is acting different you're not the guy
who's like up in the mix [__] that
you're you're about work yeah you know
what I mean I'm not going to your house
party and [__] every day and you know
whatever whatever people do I I enjoy
being in the studio and just like
working and learning new stuff so I
wouldn't say that um it's definitely you
know something to think about when I'm
moving around but most of the time I
forget right you know because it's it's
nothing makes sense these days it's I
yeah for sure I always tell people just
like we don't even know what the [__]
really going on right I don't I don't
think nobody knows what's going on so
it's like you got to be a leader at this
get off the shade R man you know what I
mean um for you I I I always wonder I
know you didn't make this beat but I
know you were very heavily a part of the
process of this album the [__] you mean
beat was insane yeah were you like when
you first just heard that beat that beat
is so crazy and that sample in that beat
just that had to be because I can only
imagine like as a producer you probably
hear a beat every once while like [__] I
wish I made that one yeah for sure and
that had to be one of those but he was
kind of like hesitant about the song
really oh yeah super hesitant like and I
was like bro this is hard like you need
to put this put this on he like you
think so I'm like yeah cuz we was locked
in and I had to go back to Atlanta for
like a week two weeks or something like
that and came back and he had it done
and he was playing me just like all the
new stuff and he played that but he was
damn there going to skip over it and I'm
like what's this he played it and I'm
like yeah this is hard and he's like you
think so I'm like bro you you need to
put this in comparison to everything
else you need to put this out like all
right was crazy yeah dunk Rock that's
that's my man dunk been working for a
long time no for sure he was sitting
outside the studio in like 2019 with a
big ass ass sign I remember that went
viral yeah that's the guy yeah that's me
recording the video oh I remember that
yeah yeah that's that's dunk Rock like
he been grinding for a long time and
like he would come to all the events
producer events in Atlanta and and La
anywhere so I've been seeing him for a
long time so when I found out that that
was his beat I was more so happy excited
about it like yeah like oh this is this
is bro like and then when it start
taking off it's like you know I like to
see that bro like if you working and you
doing you grinding like stuff that's not
normal you're not begging and it works
for you on that type of level like I was
more so happy for him that's super fire
uh you're working on like a compilation
type project yeah yeah my album yep who
who else going to be on your album uh
nobody I want to just confirm right now
you know how that [__] go you know but
it's it's definitely exciting it's
definitely something that you never
heard of and it's going to put a put a
pole inside the world of what my music
sound
like okay you know what I mean flag pole
a flag pole okay I was thinking it for
stripper pole at first n no no
you everything all
right we got to leave here and go to the
strip club uh